[Applause]
you're the produce section that we're
refreshing with that good news missed
and say hello to my trusty co-pilot
russell ross
i love you
okay ross this first story is taylor
made for you and when i found out some
details about it my jaw dropped get
ready for this oh i'm ready okay it's
the queen's platinum jubilee year and
that's 70 years on the throne um i feel
like we've been hearing about this but
these new details are going to blow your
mind all right digital spy reports that
for the first time ever the jubilee will
be televised and it's going to be hosted
by an epic duo you guys i can't even
believe i'm about to say these two names
okay are you ready for the two names yes
tom cruise and helen marin why right
where
yes it's going to be a huge star-studded
affair complete with military and
equestrian displays a 75-piece orchestra
a huge theater
uh done in four acts traveling through
royal history starting with the reign of
the queen elizabeth uh the first played
of course by helen mirren this is a play
that's going to be put on
this is this is insane
this is what we call a dream come true
all right break out the fine chyna get
me some tea and crumpets and do not
bother me until the jubilee is over
cause i'm watching
every
single
second
and i have from now on every party i
have i'm gonna call it a jubilee because
it's so fun to say i'm calling my
wedding a jubilee
[Applause]
that's exciting
well if you think that's exciting check
this out it's it's the cover the new
cover of better homes and gardens and
wowza it's hairy styles on the cover
look at this
the june issue is hot off the presses
today and available at
bhg.com and on nude stands everywhere
the interview covers harry's love of
taking a dip in a cold pool
everybody just picture that for a second
he says he swims he swims outdoors every
single day and of course his brand new
album harry's house is out next week and
i'm so excited he he says it explores
his definition of what home is he said
it's not a feeling you get from an
actual place it's internal it's a head
space and sense of well-being that you
take everywhere you go you can bring
home with you um okay here is my take on
this okay because i am really freaking
out as i think
i love magazines right like i make a
magazine okay that's how serious i'm i
love magazines i subscribe to them i
live for them yes you do every magazine
matters to me
i care so much about magazines
and when i saw this
i just thought
i
i really don't understand this happened
i want to do some deep dive
investigative reporting i want to know
who called who did harry's publicist
call better homes and gardens did better
homes and gardens reach out to him why
does harry just do whatever he wants to
do and make everything cool he's going
to change that magazine they're like
magazines watch out yes better homes and
gardens is coming from you i um i just
can't wait till he's on the cover of
popular mechanics i am really looking
forward
what make any sense
it doesn't make any sense but i'm here
for it she's so incredible yeah harry
styles you keep doing you and just
breaking all the rules and you're gonna
improve the enterprises of all the
things you touch i love harry styles all
right well speaking of another
periodical that i absolutely love travel
and leisure reports that there's a
swanky new way to get to space check
this out spaceship neptune this luxury
flight can take you to the edge of the
universe for a breathtaking 360 degree
view of our precious planet on the
outside it looks like a balloon the size
of a football field but on the inside
it's really dope
straight up dope dope in the sky
flush seats mood lighting um flights are
sold out for 2024 but you can reserve
your spot in 2025 for and here's where i
get a little grumpy 125 thousand dollars
a pop
enjoy that view
yeah
um
god i just why does this tick me off so
much well because it's a lot of money i
mean i wanted to go until i heard that
now i'm waiting for a groupon
[Applause]
totally i'm also just like we need 125
000 here on earth earth first yeah earth
first
but if
if they can figure out a way to lower
the price a little bit i would go on
this in a heartbeat and i actually think
we should do it together and do drew's
news in space are you in
if we can figure it out
if we can get a grip on yeah or we can
get them to like donate our money for
our seats to a charity i'm in i'm in too
okay done
watch out
[Music]
you